je suis embêté je suis embêté c'est un
truc qui me tire le pin
bonsoir à tous déjà il est 18h41 on est
en direct sur BT
s
je suis pas la samedi et dimanche c'est
le bordel dans le passé
6h15 sur France 2 bienvenue si vous nous
réveillez voici l'essentiel de l'info
pour les chiffres magiques sont là cinq
chiffres en train et 8 c'est parti la
pioche de Régis de Régis la pioche de
résiste c'est difficile à dire
la purge de Régis oui c'est pas facile à
dire la pioche de Régis l'approche de la
pioche de Régis la pioche de Régis
fraîche
vous pouvez pas vous appeler pierre
comme tout le monde
soyez pas mieux au fond de votre livre
vous répondez moi franchement bah on le
sait tous à 6h30 du matin parce qu'il y
a 10 minutes je voulais pas vous avez
fait un très joli la puce vous avez dit
bienvenue si vous nous réveillez
ça me va bien aussi parce que c'est un
peu dur ce matin on va pas se raconter
d'histoires je vais devoir faire des
émissions le samedi et le dimanche je
pars deux jours c'est le bordel tout le
monde ouvre sa gueule
c'est comme là le gars de l'école c'est
que tout le monde quand il est pas là
pendant 2 jours c'est il a arrêté tout
le monde bah c'est ça dégage oh molo je
suis de retour
j'ai mis le blouson pour cogner
Wilson a dit qu'il trouvait
insupportable qu'on aille chercher le
patriarc à partout y compris dans le
barbecue tout ça a des fins personnelles
et des fins d'ambition il parlait de
vous et pourtant précise-t-il je suis un
grand supporteur d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts comme il sera notre invité à 9h
c'est l'occasion de lui répondre à
Lambert Wilson sur une Rousseau et bien
j'ai envie de lui dire que j'ai vu cet
extrait que déjà ils étaient que des
hommes autour de parler de ça
[Musique]
manger ma banane je l'invite vraiment à
changer sa consommation de viande parce
que dans les gestes individuels que nous
pouvons faire pour limiter notre impact
sur la planète et bien la viande fait
partie de ceux qui ont le plus d'impact
donc Lambert Wilson plutôt que de
rentrer dans des discours qui sont d'un
autre temps vraiment changé
ben oui mais dans ces cas-là il soutient
la diminution de viande et donc voilà
c'est je peux je peux l'énerver il
m'énerve aussi voilà
[Musique]
un
oiseau
au Royaume-Uni en Corse cette nouvelle
action spectaculaire menée par les
militants écologistes pour réclamer
l'arrêt des gisements de gaz et de
pétrole ils ont cette fois entarté le
nouveau roi plutôt sa statut de cire
installé au musée Tussaud il y a 10
jours c'est une soupe à la tomate qui
avait été jetée sur les tournesols de
Van Gogh hier en Allemagne c'est un
tableau de Claude Monet qui a été
aspergé de purée une fois encore par des
militants se réclamant de la cause
environnementale mais en Allemagne les
actions radicales d'écologistes se
multiplient alarmes incendie déclenchée
dans le Parlement pour alerter sur le
réchauffement climatique ou militants
qui bloque la circulation des actions
qui divisent les Allemands vous êtes
écologique
moi si je dois je racontais ma vie
privée écologique les gens ah oui ah oui
c'est à dire moi par exemple je me lave
qu'à l'eau froide j'ai les chauffe-eau
éteint tout le temps alors quand j'ai
les invités qui arrivent j'allume vous
voyez ah vous êtes quand même courtois
et vous savez
les mesures non c'est parce que ce que
j'aime bien le froid de manière générale
on va couper le gaz sous les pattes au
début de la cuisson on va couper le
chauffage on va rouler à 100 km/h à
Paris on est déjà à 30 km/h on va mettre
là mais c'est non mais transforme en
nous en mouton ne rasthénie exactement
pareil
direction les Philippines avec une salle
de classe pas comme les autres
pour éviter la triche cette professeure
a demandé à ses étudiants de porter un
chapeau lors de leur examen sans
consigne particulière ces élèves
ingénieurs ont fait preuve de beaucoup
d'imagination avec des casques parfois
très spartiate ses photos amusent
beaucoup en ligne où elles sont très
partagées et l'enseignante et d'autant
plus fier de ces élèves qu'ils ont
particulièrement réussi leur examen
cette année c'est pas un geste militant
pour elle le porte du pantalon c'est une
nécessité pour pouvoir faire ce qu'elle
a envie de faire
[Musique]
et donc Rosa va obtenir cette
autorisation de porter le pantalon elle
sera la première femme en France avoir
une autorisation officielle pour porter
le pantalon
c'est bon je suis là je suis là je suis
là
[Musique]